Web app install banners give
you the ability to quickly and
seamlessly add your web
app to their home screen,
making it easy to launch and
return to your app.
The best part, Chrome handles most
of the heavy lifting for you.
Prompting the user to add your web app
to their home screen is a powerful
feature.
Before showing the Add to
Home Screen banner, Chrome looks for
several heuristics to ensure
a great user experience.
It needs to use service workers
to provide an offline experience.
Apps that are added to the home screen
should be fast and always available.
No Offlinosaurus.
It needs to have a web manifest
file to define what to launch and
how to launch it.
And it needs to have an engaged user.
Currently, that means two navigations
within at least five minutes, but
that will change in the future.
When these heuristics are met,
Chrome will show the Add to Home Screen
banner across the bottom of the page.
We've set the bar high because
it's important when users see
the Add to Home Screen banner, they
know that the app that they're going to
be adding will be reliable,
fast and engaging.
It some cases,
you might want to defer or even cancel
the banner until more convenient time.
For example, an e-commerce
company might want to defer it
until the user is in a check out flow
and they've completed the transaction.
Check the link in the instructor notes
for more details on how you can add
analytics to the prompt and understand
how users are responding to the banner.
For testing, you can disable
the engagement checks by enabling
the #bypass-app-banner-engagement-checks
in Chrome and restarting the browser.
[BLANK_AUDIO]